hi that guys i'm new seat here with mark
walton we're here at Gamescom 2014 walk
we've been seeing a PlayStation 4 game
this morning that we thought was gonna
be on ps3 but it has changed it was dead
it was gone for years then all of a
sudden like the Phoenix in the ashes
ashes so this is until dawn which was
originally a rocky sore teen horror
thing and now they've gone you know what
screw it we've got all the power on the
ps4 I mean all the graphics all the
lighting effects all that facial
animation stuff in there let's make it
dark let's make it pretty let's make it
proper or so the ps3 version of the game
was gonna be first person you need the
PlayStation movers like it torch now
it's ps4 its third person it has some I
mean that facial animation and the
motion capture is incredible so they've
got some big names they have hayden
Panettiere Panish alcala panettiere from
heroes and when the rolls and it's it's
I mean it it's quite Eleanor I guess off
as well in the app that you pick up
items and you can inspect them and go
yeah i saw facial animation is out as
well no the facial animation looks
amazing like you can tell they've done a
lot of work with the actors to sort of
do that to get it right you know you
mentioned there LA noire I definitely
got that and the sort of the way you
pick up clues and it uses the motion
controls of the pad so yes it doesn't
have moved but there's still an element
of that you sort of turn objects over to
look for clues and he also reminded me a
bit of a heavy rain yes as well and a
lot of ways you interact with things and
it's sort of you know it's trying to
tell a story above all else and yes
there are gameplay elements in there but
it is about the story and that's
probably the most interesting part of a
game is that it's not just one story now
this bad boy has what they claim as
thousands of different endings so
surreal butterfly that kind of thing and
in fact when you make a decision or you
pick up something about if I does appear
on the screen to illustrate that you've
made a potentially game altering choice
which is the cool and the end of the
demo the guys from super must have run
us through and he was like so I picked
up this clue but I missed this one I
made this moral decision well yeah it's
a pretty heavy moral decision but it
affects completely how your games gonna
play out it's not just picking an ending
all of these little little bits come
together and really change how your
story plays out yeah it was quite
amazing like they they were saying that
there's thousands of fermentation for
the ending but in between that there are
actually lots of little decisions that
only affect that individuals story as
well and so as you're sort of game goes
on like we just got so many branches in
which your story can go and they were
saying that all the characters in the
game can buy yeah so no one's any point
I you can screw that up totally and then
all be dead and then you know you've got
pletely different ending if I think is
is super cool but I'm intl game itself
we saw um sort of a decent chunk we go
through so far yeah a decent half-hour
chunk and there were lots of there lots
of good scares I mean certainly in the
room here in a black title the lights
and there was a new screen there was a
woman who screamed yes
no thing I thought about it is and so
like the original ps3 version was kind
of like those I know what you did last
summer kind of quite campy teenage
horror movies this one kind of felt like
one of those horror movies you get from
the mid noughties where everything was
like a bluey gray palette color tone and
everything was really serious and you
had those names that you'd recognize and
this is kind of what the new you until
dawn felt like yeah absolutely i mean
there was some cool i mean scary clan
ham oh my god he was like Pennywise the
clown but his his jaw is super weird
anything that's my classic horror movie
distorted voice and it kind of an inland
elements of sore in it as well for the
psychological manipulation like one
night I had the the previously on so
every time you load up your game if
you've not played it in a while it'll
show you a little recap of your
decisions your game altering decisions
in a kind of you know previously on lost
type situation but previous on until
dawn last week yeah absolutely i mean we
make cinematically oh yeah i mean we're
not talking too much about the story
here except you know it's a story based
game will give it away but suffice to
say you know it it was quite creepy
quite scary i'm super keen to buy it
me too so until dawn is going to come
out PlayStation boy I'm certainly very
excited to see more of it for the latest
here from games come stay tuned here the
game spot so for all the latest to make
sure you t Oh fine do that again let's
go so well